one other news more than 100 million
Americans are in the path of a powerful
winter storm this morning the massive
systems are bringing snow ice and rain
from the Pacific Northwest to the
Midwest and into the Northeast snow
covered roads are causing problems for
drivers from Tacoma Washington to Cedar
Rapids Iowa and Chicago the storm is
responsible for at least one death Don
Dahler is in Philadelphia where a winter
winter weather advisory is now in effect
John a good morning good morning that
winter weather advisory is actually in
effect until 6:00 p.m. for the millions
of people who are taking to the roads
their commute is a nightmare under
treacherous conditions they are looking
at snow ice sleet and it's only gonna
get worse it's a mess it's a complete
mess heavy snow and ice created havoc on
the roads slippin and slidin I have the
drive slow like a turtle overturned cars
littered interstates across the Midwest
it doesn't matter what you're driving
you could end up in the ditch dashcam
video shows a car slamming into a park
police vehicle on the side of a highway
in Waterloo Iowa a private jet with
three people on board slid off a runway
in Richmond Indiana after attempting to
land no one was hurt up north in
Philadelphia a bus crashed into the side
of a building overnight after hitting a
patch of ice one person on board was
injured so it's gonna be a mess pretty
much everywhere New Jersey Governor Phil
Murphy has declared a state of emergency
nearly 1400 salt and plow trucks are on
the roads across New Jersey and New York
I can't take any more snow it's wet
sloppy heavy in the Pacific Northwest
where this massive storm began emergency
vehicles were forced to push buses that
became trapped after days of snowfall in
Seattle this is actually probably the
worst I've seen and the city's homeless
are struggling to stay warm when the
shelters closed standing under Boeing's
and shelters of course kicking us out at
7 o'clock in the morning it's still
going to be frozen over in treacherous
Seattle has seen record snowfall over 20
inches in the past 12 days it is the
snowiest February they're on record as
for the Northeast
they're expecting this storm to continue
until tomorrow
Oh John alright Don thank you